foreign
comes from Bill in Rhode Island bill
says I'm 37 and I really found myself in
a lucky spot just three years ago I was
making around 50 Grand and now I'm
clearing over a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars as a cloud engineer
brain dancer he's a rain dancer correct
just making sure you know what that is
my wife and I combined make about a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars and
to be honest for people like us man I
hate that language but I know it I feel
it in my guts it's a bit overwhelming we
have student debt which we were
attacking hard and we have recently been
writing checks towards that debt that
used to be what we made for an entire
month my question is how do you
psychologically process this amount of
money growth and don't feel shaken up
when paying off large sums of debt I
also know more is coming as my wife and
I are committed to not allow I'm not
even at a management level which on
average comes with a 30 increase my wife
and I are committed not to allow our
growth and income to become the life
sucker I've heard about on this show
I get this at a in my bones because I
grew up with not a lot and money was a
big struggle at my home and Dave you and
I I've come to you for wisdom on this
um
because money was for those people and
vacations were what those guys did and
those shoes were what they and those
cars were for them and it was it it's
it's bizarre finding yourself
in those shoes and then saying what I do
because I'm not them I'm one of those
right
there's two things you gotta process
there
um one is uh am I worthy of this and
he's got that language I I just got
lucky there's all that in there and so
yeah you got to walk away from that part
of it and then the second part is
kind of I think more maybe even more
what he's asking about but he didn't
realize it is
um
you do have to psychologically adjust to
more money I mean it's it's it's a thing
I mean I like we spend more on coffee
at Ramsey per month
for the team here than I used to make in
a year
I have to psychologically adjust to that
I mean when I sit down and I see that on
the p l p l it's still
simultaneously pisses me off scares me
makes me feel proud right exactly all
this all at the same time yes all the
same time like what and oh God and well
I guess I can do that you know yeah yeah
simultaneously right and so it's God and
it but it's it's zeros it's emotional
and uh the only way I have found for
that part of it not the identity part
but the part of just the shock of the
zeros of I spend more on blank than I
ever made in a year which is kind of
what he said he just sent off more of
the Sally made than I ever made in a
year before or a month before or
whatever it is you just the only way you
you get used to it is you do it more
you just you live anymore I mean so
somebody that has lived with a 300 000
income
for 10 years is more psychologically
adjusted to that than someone who's
lived with it for three months that's
right and so that that's normal so that
will solve itself uh and you got to be
careful because you can get
to taking it for granted kind of a thing
um and not counting your blessings and
all of those sorts of things not feeling
grateful for them you deserve now I
deserve 300 what do you mean just 300.
you know never himself 300 there's 300
pennies you know
um and but no no I am but then the
second part of it is you know are you
worthy and you know you have to that's a
spiritual
walk and a psychological walk to say
okay what makes me worth something in
the marketplace is it my is it God loves
me more well no he loves poor people as
much as he loves rich people and he
loves rich people as much as he loves
poor people for those of you that are
socialists and so um he loves everybody
that and he doesn't like that you know
you'll love one kid that's talented more
than the kid that's not talented sure
um you know you they're just all my kids
I got you know everybody's got a
spectrum of them you know and so that's
part of it so God it's not a God's love
thing he's not blessing you beyond
someone else
um so what is it that's causing the
money it's you're doing something that's
worth more to society it's an economic
transaction and once you kind of
separate that out from your spiritual
Worth or your psychological Worth or and
then some idiot from the old
neighborhood will say something like
you've gotten too big for your breath oh
yeah
like you noticed yeah I've been putting
on the weight locking Donuts but yeah I
had to change britches a time or two but
that wasn't what they were meant that's
right they were talking about my
waistline they were talking about uh
you're fancy now yeah you're fancy now
and you know that happened actually on
this show you know you go back and
listen to
this show if you could get a tape of it
from 20 years ago it's been I've been on
there for 30 years it sounds
ridiculously exactly the same
like the same level of boldness the same
level of carrying on the same level or
whatever same level of kindness and
compassion when someone's hurting the
same level of interface when you're
stupid and and yet it never fails that
someone comes along they go you know I
used to listen to you but now now that
you've gotten big
you know now you changed well I didn't
change honey go back and listen to other
shows you're the one changed
so I think that's interesting I've had
to get rid of for People Like Us
language like he writes about this
question because I had pigeonholed
myself as identity it's an identity yeah
and you gave me some wisdom early on
that has really been important for me in
fact just this morning I was talking to
Hank about it my 12 year old
um you said when you're making this
transition remember ratios and that's
been very important for me in that like
you like man if we could scratch
together Sheila and I we could scratch
together enough to get some spaghetti
every day for the week man that was
great yeah right and then we went out
with a couple from work the other day
and the bill came and I thought that I
used to be a lot of groceries right and
but the percentage of right and the
percentage of what my take-home salary
what used to be versus and so in my debt
income all that the ratio has been
really important yeah it just it tells
you if you're out of line that's exactly
right okay because you're not people
like you used to be you're people like
you are now that's right and so don't I
you know your identity can be I came
from there it's like condoleezza's
Rice's uh uh line it doesn't matter
where you're coming from all the matters
where you're going to that's right and
so you know if you where you grew up is
is part of your story but it is not
necessarily who you are today that's
right your level of education is part of
your story but it's not necessarily who
you are today
um these are all elements of who you are
today but
um I'm not the same person
that little David Ramsey at 3713
Faulkner driveway and thank goodness
right yeah because he wasn't real bright
John deloney wasn't either but also
Imagine the dumb butt stuff I've done on
a bus I appreciate you
and everyone we work with
um
I I think the ethos of this place it's
right over there on the wall don't
despise humble beginnings
um always making sure we're tipping
folks and taking care of people never
forgetting those moments that when when
you couldn't rub two pennies together
right I think I think there's an ethos
here yeah and and in that sense you
remember
you know what is the the hillbilly my
hillbilly upbringing don't forget your
raising I'll Always Love raisins but I
don't know what they're talking about
don't forget your Asian how you were
brought up don't forget how you're
brought up right and so there's some
good things you want to do with that I'm
loyal to vendors that have been with us
forever because part of my raising was
you dance with a girl that brought you
yep you know so there's some good things
in there
um that you stick with that are
principles but the identity that the
only way I'm holy me is to be poor
right not true that's right that's a
that's a false identity so yeah there's
two things you have to do is one you
have to adjust the identity and the
second thing is you just get used to
practice with ratios the uh the use of
money of that amount and it's going to
mean you're driving cars and you're
going to look up and you go I got a
friend made 15 million dollars last year
and he drove up the other day in a 400
000 car and I'm like
oh wait a minute it's it's less than a
guy making 150 000 spending on a four
thousand dollar car exactly the same
ratio
it's no big deal yeah I mean he could
drive a stupid thing off a cliff and as
long as nobody's hurt it ain't gonna
hurt him he'll be all right it's like
you know but it's in my where you know
where you come from is like your system